today I'm starting with explosive and
stunning Revelations from the Dominion
lawsuit against Fox News we have learned
in the last few hours that Rupert
Murdoch of news corporation admitted
under oath that yes Fox News hosts were
promoting election lies now we all knew
this but it is a massive story of huge
consequence yeah Rupert Murdoch can
afford to pay most likely whatever comes
of this lawsuit but this genuinely could
could harm Fox News in a serious way
let's get right to what we've learned
mediaite has a report Rupert Murdoch
admitted under oath Fox News hosts
promoted election lies on air despite a
raft of evidence revealing that many
hosts privately knew that the claims
made by then president Donald Trump and
his surrogates were false stunning new
details emerged in more court documents
released yesterday afternoon
in the Dominion voting system defamation
lawsuit against Fox News as chairman of
Fox News parent company of fox
Corporation Murdoch is a central figure
in the 1.6 billion dollar damages claim
according to the copy of the filing
obtained by mediaite Murdoch admitted in
a deposition last month that fall
selection claims were promoted by top
hosts at the Cable News Network quote
they endorsed I would have liked us to
be stronger in denouncing it in
hindsight said Murdoch Murdoch was asked
to host Janine Pirro endorsed the claims
Murdoch said I think so he said Lou
Dobbs endorsed the claims quote a lot
and Sean Hannity did so a bit
when asked if he could have told Fox to
stop inviting Trump lawyers Sydney
Powell and Rudy Giuliani on the air
Murdoch replied I could have but I
didn't arguably as big a revelation
Murdoch helped the Trump campaign by
providing Biden television ads to Jared
Kushner before they ran on Fox News
these are massive Revelations keep in
mind that Fox News hosted a presidential
debate in 2020 as if they were some kind
of neutral Observer or Arbiter but
behind the scenes look at what was going
on
um Yahoo news via Bloomberg also with an
interesting article worth looking at
Murdoch testified Fox commentators
endorsed Trump's 2020 election lie Fox
News Fox Corporation chairman Rupert
Murdoch testified that Fox's popular
commentators endorsed that's the word he
used endorse Trump's false claim that
the 2020 election was rigged even though
Murdoch said he doubted it right away he
doubted it right away
um there's an interesting transcript
here where it says Murdoch testified
that he doubted Trump's conspiracy
theory right away is it is it it is fair
to say you seriously doubted any claim
of massive election fraud Murdoch was
asked by a lawyer oh yeah Murdoch said
and you seriously doubted it from the
beginning he was asked yeah Murdoch
replied I mean we thought everything was
on the up and up I think that was shown
when we announced Arizona of course
referring to when Fox declared Biden the
winner of Arizona
this is an incredible media story and
you know whatever you think of of uh uh
the the sort of Gossip World there was
that very big Hulk Hogan
um case involving because I didn't
follow it I don't even know which
tabloid it was and he essentially put
them out of business and there was sort
of like do you care about Hulk Hogan but
then there was what does this mean more
generally about the caution that media
Outlets have to have and this could be a
significantly more a consequential story
now there's a couple different things
that I think are important to mention it
would be really great
if this seriously damaged Fox News as
far as the broadcast side now that's not
because I want to suppress speech it's
not because I want to violate anyone's
First Amendment rights it's because
actions
should have consequences and one of the
things that I've said before is that the
bigger your platform the more seriously
you should take your responsibility for
what you put out on air and the more you
should want to be accurate in what you
say
and even as it applies to my program now
that the show is as big as it is which
is still way smaller than these other
platforms we're talking about I am extra
careful when it comes to making sure
that I'm getting as close to the truth
always on the program when it comes to
the facts that I'm presenting then I
give my opinion sure it's not that I
didn't care about it when the show was
smaller but I sense the responsibility
and I know that the repercussions for
getting even Minor Details wrong are
greater the larger you are Fox News as
one of the three biggest cable news
networks and I know people say David
it's not really news I know but we're
colloquially we're talking about the
three biggest cable news networks MSNBC
CNN Fox News they not accidentally but
knowingly spent months promoting claims
about the election that they knew to be
lies the result of which was I don't
want to say irreversibly corrosive to
our democracy but it has still damaged
our democracy to this day as we continue
to see these claims being made now as
far as the impact the lawsuit is likely
to have on Fox News even if they deserve
for it to be very damaging they will
continue to lie they will continue to
monetize by playing to the lowest common
denominator of the American right wing
even if on a personal level Hannity and
Ingram and Tucker and Rupert Murdoch all
know that they're saying things that
aren't true and that they're inviting
guests on to say things that aren't true
as Tucker Carlson knew about Sydney
Powell
the money part of it
you know Rupert Murdoch can probably
afford whatever comes of this is the
reality his goal now is to minimize the
damage to the platform
and it remains to be seen where this
goes but an extraordinary Revelation and
my guess is we are going to learn even
more in the days to come imagine for a
second that you try logging into your
email account only to find that your
password was changed an hour ago and
then you get notifications of activity
from your bank and then your credit
cards that is what identity theft is
like and it's a horrible feeling and we
dealt with it at the show not that long
ago but now I have an app called Aura
which gives me much more peace of mind
our sponsor Aura is the all-in-one
solution for keeping your online account
safe because Aura will scan the dark web
for your personal info passwords social
security number and you get fast alerts
when they find something you also get
fast alerts about credit inquiries Aura
protects all of your devices from
malware or even requests the removal of
your info from data broker sites and or
helps you manage what your kids can do
on their devices you can restrict
certain apps set screen time limits set
Focus times when you need them off of
devices go to aura.com Pacman to try it
free for seven days your login
credentials might already be floating
around out there and Aura will tell you
instantly for free the link is down
below